President Trump is in the UK and already
making waves holding a press conference
with British Prime Minister Theresa May
the president down ploink down plane
scuse me the fallout of a controversial
interview he gave to British newspaper
the Sun where he accused me of wrecking
brexit and killing off any chance of a
vital US trade deal
I didn't criticize the Prime Minister
have a lot of respect for the Prime
Minister and unfortunately there was a
story that was done which was you know
generally fine but it didn't put in what
I said about the Prime Minister and I
said tremendous things it's called fake
news she's gonna make a decision as to
what she's going to do the only thing I
ask of Teresa is that we make sure we
can trade that we don't have any
restrictions because we want to trade
with the UK and the UK wants to trade
with us the president President was met
with thousands of protesters and a giant
flying Trump a baby blimp in London
which he said made him feel unwelcome to
make me feel unwelcome no reason for me
to go to London I loved I used to love
London is the city I haven't been there
in a long time but when they make you
feel unwelcome why would I say they're
angry demonstrators as Trump's tough
stance on immigration a subject he also
broached during his press conference
warning Europe about the potential risks
I think it's been very bad for Europe I
think Europe is a place I know very well
and I think that what has happened is
very tough it's a very tough situation I
mean you see the same terror attacks
that I do I know it's politically not
necessarily correct to say that but I'll
say it and I'll say it loud and I think
they better watch themselves Greg you
lived in the UK let's start with London
it was amazing to me that that many
people had the day off - just on a
Friday afternoon
the interesting thing number one is the
balloon has absolutely no effect because
Trump is actually bigger than the
balloon I mean he actually is as a
phenomenon where ever he goes has a
greater impact than anything there so he
is
number one story in England he's the
biggest thing in England he's bigger
than Big Ben I want to make a metaphor
an analogy if I may to my friends in
England I live there I'm an Anglophile I
love the music in the 1970s music was
plagued by soft rock and progressive
rock things like air supply and Genesis
and Emerson Lake and Palmer just really
boring ponderous music Papa songs with
15-minute drum solos then in 1976 The
Ramones The Ramones from New York Queens
Queens went to England and played and
what happened destroyed the meat that
whole scene and all these punk bands
started The Clash The Damned The Sex
Pistols
thousands of new bands happen sound
familiar Donald Trump is the Ramones of
politics he and what he's done is what
what punk did to music Trump is doing to
the entire political scene he's he's a
brutal blunt game-changing but he's
elementally true you may not like punk
rock but the messages in the songs were
were true there were three minutes two
minutes of truth that's what you're
seeing this is the first punk-rock
president is that the metaphor you said
was gonna be blue yes I got it from a
buddy of mine my buddy Paul emailed me
last night said you know he's a punk
rock president now go yes on crack
president I mean I like a country music
president too you have Wynette's GW Bush
you want to carry this metaphor forward
because I was actually thinking of
something similar because everyone a
focus is on the way President Trump says
things but they but the way he says it
makes you focus on what he's saying
for instance if President Trump hadn't
said that Germany was held captive by
Russia we wouldn't be talking about
something like the Nordstrom to pipeline
which is important because it does in
fact give Russia leverage over Germany
and other European nations so it is
something important especially at a time
we know when we're all talking about
Russia aggression and we're looking at
putting sanctions on Russia had sort of
undercuts that narrative and that
objective if they're funneling money to
the Russia through the pipeline but we
wouldn't be talking about that if he
didn't say it that way or you look at
immigration all you have to do is look
at the Paris attackers the the ease that
they are able to get around Europe go
back to Syria come back hiding in places
like mall and beak which are the epitome
of a
failure of integration of immigration
policies and the lack of assimilation so
I mean he says these things and at the
face it seems outlandish but will we be
talking about the substance if you
didn't say it in that way I don't know I
do I was just thinking though about the
the Teresa may comments Jessi and he
said we gave the interview to the son
they released the audio he said it was
fake but I do think that he actually
maybe felt a little bad that she felt
slighted in her own paper while he was
there I think he did feel bad he felt a
human emotion that is possible with this
president and a lot of people think he's
just this maniacal robot that doesn't
care about people's feelings but the way
he was kind of over-the-top praising her
as the strong decisive ally that is a
big winner and when he calls me favor
because now we're gonna get a trade deal
looks like exactly I remember when
President Obama said that you know if
you guys do brexit we're gonna get in
the back of the line on the trade he's
done the opposite and he's reached his
arm across the Atlantic and offered an
olive branch there I thought meeting the
Queen was the bigger thing today just
the the visual that was pumped into the
world and when we see this on television
people enjoy the spectacle of it they
let the red and the colors and the she's
in the blue and the president's trying
to walk like this and it's just very
formal and it shows how the president
was respected I know the president
personally enjoys that kind of pomp and
circumstance he enjoys the respect than
rolling out the red carpet but it really
solidified the special relationship
today he also saw the image of him
holding Teresa Mae's hand and and then
they had tea with the Queen and he
probably gave him a big boost of
adrenaline at the end of this and at the
end of it when you look at it they the
European countries did make commitments
to boost their defense spending and NATO
is invigorated I believe and more
focused on the task at hand and on
confronting Russia so I think at the end
of the day the trip to Europe was
positive and we've had great economic
news this week strong humiliated himself
immigration we should send the kids from
the quaint from Queens over to London
why not it changed it change the world
but what Trump said that in fact these
immigrants are tearing the fabric of
Europe and and and London apart
and he goes after the mayor and by the
way Jesse he says that he loves Teresa
mate you know what he's the one that
gave the interview it's not like
somebody forced him to talk to the Sun
newspaper he gave an interview that was
hostile towards a leader he was about to
sit down he created the chaos he created
this situation and then he created the
making up together one that might work
out in Teresa may's favor right because
it could but it put him a little bit on
the defensive and it put him in a
position of being quite amiable and so
because she was gracious and she was
like oh no problem it's fine like very
British you know stiff upper lip
no problem she's gonna walk away with
possibly getting a trade deal when
earlier in the week her government was
falling apart I don't know I think Boris
Johnson left I don't know that they were
how close they are to actually falling
apart he says she's a strong leader he
wishes there were more lead I don't know
but I will say he goes over there he
stirs the pot then he tries to on stir
the pot again he is you know the be all
of the whole story but to me you can't
get over the fact that 100,000 people in
the streets of London I mean forget the
crime the London protesters I saw
Benjamin Hall earlier reporting in that
two o'clock hour was that they were
really campaigning against capitalism no
it's true a lot of this is what happens
with left-wing protesters it becomes a
grab-bag of everything you saw women
dressed up as characters from The
Handmaid's Tale which is the fictional
miniseries about masata misogynistic
dystopia where women are forced into
sexual slavery now I doubt any of those
women dressed up as those handmaids
ever did anything about the mass rape in
England would ask yeah an erotic run dam
run Rotterdam Rotterdam Raqqa down
Rotherham the sexual slavery that took
place there was an absolute scandal that
went on for years
and I don't see any signs for that now
it's Batu - to one's point everybody
hates his style
everybody hates his style that's why
he's punk rock
he put the New York Times even had to
admit today was it today's paper
the headline was Trump got everything
Obama ever asked for I don't see that
headline but it sounds like a good one
thank you that's not Fitness that's a
New York Times I agree I think you guys
understand in a way he's not even
playing to the Europeans he's not
playing yet recently everybody plays to
their domestic audience right so he's
playing to an American base when he
brings up the immigration issue he's
trying to stir that up here I think he
talks about there is no truth are you
kidding Europe at me what a Teresa may
say as she was standing there next to
him immigration has been great for Great
Britain that's what she taught from
Germany to Denmark to Swede into all of
these populates the populace are rising
up because of it correct so I think he's
playing to a populist nationalist
sentiments that he would like to excite
here at home for the midterms but that
is not it's not the case what are you
that you are breaking apart Europe and
the fabric is being torn and that the
mayor of London is responsible see one
of the signs that they had today that I
thought was kind of preposterous it said
no to Trump no to war really not the war
mongers the war on the press today who
said these are not you know the
downtrodden you know lower class people
that have been crushed by the industrial
level these are people in alastair that
come from snobby backgrounds and went to
nice prep schools that can afford to
take the friday afternoon off